Speaker 1: You can also join the discussion on
the David Pakman Show subreddit that's at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit. Nearly 34000 of our
viewers and listeners are now subscribed there.
Spotted a few interesting posts this morning that
I wanted to talk about. One user asks, Does David
think the word Karen should be burnable in the
past? He said This is a racially charged word.
Speaker 2: No, I don't think.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, bendable by who?
We don't ban people for using it. What I've said
before is I make every effort not to use any words
Speaker 2: that are pejoratives
Speaker 1: grouping people by race. And while
Speaker 2: I don't know if it's
Speaker 1: explicit or not, Karen is essentially a
Speaker 2: pejorative about entitled
Speaker 1: white women. And so I see no
reason to use the term. It's conceivable that
it may have gotten into a YouTube title or to
a while ago, but I've stopped using it and as an
editorial thing, I don't think it's particularly
useful. The question about bands,
Speaker 2: I think is related
Speaker 1: to recently there was this big dustup
on Twitch, where two streamers that are kind of in
our universe Hassan Piker and Ian Vash were banned
for using the word. I mean, I guess I have to be
careful. It's a word, you know, saltines
Speaker 2: would be in this
Speaker 1: category. A cheat Cheez-Its would
be in this category. It's it's a pejorative
for white people.
Speaker 2: They
were banned and a bunch of people on the
Speaker 1: left kind of came out defending it,
saying the word isn't really racially charged.
I see it as racially charged. And so my take was
Speaker 2: again, I don't think it's
Speaker 1: really a word progressive should
use. It's a it's a pejorative
Speaker 2: about white
Speaker 1: people. If you think about the word, it
doesn't apply. You don't think about Asians when
the word is said. You don't think about Native
Americans, it's about white people. I avoid
pejoratives that group of people by race. Now,
you know, twitch bans in terms of service. I
don't know. I think it's all kind of dumb. But the
point is, if you're banned for using the N-word,
it's not shocking that you would be banned for
using a pejorative about white people, even if
they don't have the same historical weight,
Speaker 2: which they don't.
Speaker 1: And I admit so that's my view
about Karen. That's my view about the C-word,
the N-word, etc.. Another post that I spotted
Biden official warns COVID explosion imminent.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So listen, there's
Speaker 1: there's bad news, and then
there's maybe OK news when it comes to COVID,
I've not been covering the day to day of the
Omicron variant because information is changing
so quickly. If we look at the U.K. right now,
they are seeing record cases. It's wild
what's going on in the U.K.. That being said,
the U.K. is doing a lot of testing. And
the data we have right now still points to
Speaker 2: Omicron being more mild.
Speaker 1: Is it as mild as the flu,
which is about a fifth, as
Speaker 2: deadly as the original
Speaker 1: COVID strains? We don't know.
Speaker 2: Should people still
get vaccinated and boost it?
Speaker 1: Yes, absolutely. Should
the immunocompromised and others
take serious precautions? Yes.
But the potentially less bad thing
is that at the individual level,
Omicron may be milder, and it continues to point
that way. The problem is, you have to remember.
As an individual, if all Macron is
Speaker 2: more mild,
if you get it, you're less
Speaker 1: likely to be seriously ill
at the population level if it's significantly
more contagious, even though any one person's
odds of getting really sick are lower.
It'll still fill up the hospitals. And
if you think about burden of disease, if it's
half as deadly but three times as contagious,
Speaker 2: if I get it,
Speaker 1: it's less likely for me that
it will be serious. But it's still going to lead
to way more people getting very, very sick. So,
you know, I'm still waiting for something more
definitive, but that's the way it looks so far.
Last post I spotted what is up with the weird
lighting and David studio. Is it just me or is
it dimmer? Seems. If he's trying to switch things
up now, what's going on is I've been on the road
and our new mechanism, you know, it's the
audience is very physical and emotional.
And sometimes when it's clear that
Speaker 2: I'm on the road and have
a different background,
Speaker 1: people get
very mad. I mean, it's crazy.
Speaker 2: Sometimes people
get mad that I'm doing some things. Sometimes
people get mad that I'm not in the studio.
Speaker 1: So for a while now, when I'm on the
road, I've been using a green screen and it
Speaker 2: replicates the home studio.
Speaker 1: Now some people notice I'm in a
different place because my mike is different
or the lighting is a little different or whatever.
Speaker 2: This time around, the equipment
Speaker 1: I chose
Speaker 2: is not quite as
good. So things are a little bit degraded.
Speaker 1: I've two weeks in the past on
the road and people haven't noticed
when I've had other equipment with me.
This time it's noticeable we're going to
try to do better next time. You can join the
Speaker 2: discussion at David
Speaker 1: Pakman dot com slash. Read it